new fresh exciting that's what I want
the time is now they have no idea what's
going to happen do you profess your
belief
yeah we talked
hey youtubers is charlie so HBO dropped
another spring teaser with a little bit
of Game of Thrones footage so let's talk
about Jaime Lannister and Dan and Dave
revealed something about what's going on
with brand storyline so let's talk about
that too so just careful for spoilers
from book 4 i'm going to be talking a
little bit about jamie in the siege of
Riverrun and most of the stuff that Dan
and Dave said about brands character is
just a logical extension of his story so
I guess you can say spoiler warning for
everything that has happened to brand so
far too so let's talk about the army of
flowers in the background there those
are tyrell shields marching in the
background so either a Tyrell army
marches its way into King's Landing to
defend Marjorie and Loras during the
trial of the faith or this is in another
place and jamie has gone all the way to
Highgarden because it mostly seems like
Jamie's going to be going to Riverrun
this year he could also did a high
garden but I'm thinking that this is
still in King's Landing so it might be
from earlier in the season because they
still have to address the trial of the
faith now in the high Sparrow was trying
to get the confession out of Cersei he
said that Marjorie and Loras would be
looked upon favorably because they
confess their sins but he didn't say
they were off scot-free he just said
that they would be looked upon favorably
meaning the whole context that situation
was that he really wanted to get Cersei
she was the big fish to fry but in the
lead-up to the last couple of episodes
the queen of thorns was starting to
freak out a little like I will totally
bring an army to King's Landing cut off
your grain supply if you don't help me
out no surprise Cersei biting off a
little bit more than she can handle and
now that Tywin is dead there is no one
left in King's Landing to challenge her
because Tom and will do whatever she
says she had that look on her face as
Robert strong picked her up and carried
her off at the end like I'm going to
crush everyone so probably no
coincidence that the Tyrell Army is
marching into King's Landing unless they
are really in Highgarden I don't think
it's in Highgarden but it's too hard to
tell just from the shields marching in
the background in the crowd there have
been rumors at the blackfish and Edmure
Tully are back meaning that they would
have to circle back around and do the
siege of Riverrun storyline from the
book that they skipped that was from
book 4 but the whole timeline of book 4
has already been changed with respect to
his storyline Jamie doesn't find out
about Circe's trial with the faith he
doesn't find out that she gets thrown in
prison till the end of book for and he
actually when he gets the letter he
burns it he does not go straight away to
help
no it seems kind of cold but you have to
keep in mind in the books the last time
that they had the twin sets what you
know Jamie's sward off after their last
time was over Joffrey's dead body at the
funeral probably one of the more
controversial scenes from season four
and as you saw since then season five
changed that elope Jamie feels the
emotional pull of Circe a lot more than
book Jamie does at this point so inside
Jamie's head we're way off book so
circling back around to the siege of
Riverrun you know where you bring the
black fish in EM your back into the
story so what happens to Riverrun in the
wake of the red wedding is the blackfish
escapes the phrase goes back to Riverrun
and fortifies the castle so that the
Lannisters in the phrase both have to
lay siege to it to try and get him out
Cersei in the crown are trying to
install the phrase as Lords of Riverrun
and it becomes this protracted battle
that lasts for a long time just to give
some credit to the dearly departed
Stannis the siege of Riverrun doesn't
last nearly as long as the siege of
storms ended during Robert's rebellion
so Stannis way more hardcore than the
blackfish even though the blackfish is
still a badass but in the book after
Tywin's death Cersei sends Jamie to
Riverrun to dispatch the King's justice
to the blackfish so the phrase could get
inside so if Tywin's funeral was at the
beginning of season five you can see how
much they've already changed Jamie's
story line that's why you heard all the
groans when Jamie went to door and
they're like oh that he's going to Dorne
I can't believe it what happened to
Riverrun but the good thing about them
bringing the story back around a doing
siege of Riverrun even if it's going to
be a vastly different version of the
story line is that you get to do phrase
again in the North remembers technically
Riverrun is not in the north but they
were bound to Robb Stark Kalin Stark was
a Tully so the red wedding is still an
open wound in their mind and I know it's
always a point of contention as to where
Jaime and Brienne storyline is going
because brands been in the North trying
to help the Starks on the mission Jaime
put her on and jamie has been stuck in
Dorne trying and failing to save
Marcella but if Jamie goes to Riverrun
he's that much closer they could run
into each other I believe in the preview
chapters that George are Martin has
released four winds of winter Jaime and
Brienne do have a meetup so we may or
may not get some more Jamie Brienne
scenes but it just it depends on how far
north Jamie goes when Cersei sends him
to end the siege of Riverrun he
essentially spends the rest of his time
just going around taking care of the
remnants of Robb Stark's army so he is
just like
touring around up in that area speaking
of the TV show Dan and Dave offered a
little bit of an explainer on brands
picture here with the short hair why
he's riding a horse so if you missed the
brand video it did I talked a little bit
about how he's basically just stuck in
that tree learning about the green site
from the Bloodraven but in this picture
for season six he's already left the
tree riding around on a horse Dana Dave
have now explained that he is kind of
like Luke Skywalker in Return of the
Jedi they actually used the star wars
reference there like at the beginning of
Return of the Jedi Luke Skywalker just
shows up at Jabba's palace full-blown
Jedi he's clearly been training a lot
but you don't know you like there's this
big missing time frame that you don't
know about where he's gone away and come
back with a lot more power so that's
kind of what's going on with brand in
season six like they make it sound like
they're gonna deal with his training his
green site training in flashback or like
in a really quick way so it'll already
be really powerful when we see him so I
know something you'll be really upset by
that because you want to see a whole
bunch of we're would flashbacks I still
think we'll get some but it just seems
like they're speeding through that Yoda
training montage like running through
daga bud jumping doing flips over stuff
now I don't imply that he's going to be
the one to save John Snow I know a lot
of you have asked me that like if Jon
Snow is resurrected is brain gonna do it
I don't think that's the case but I do
think that he will be very important to
the wall when they try to fight the army
of White Walkers all Dan and Dave did
was make that Luke Skywalker Return of
the Jedi analogy bran will already have
great power in season six so make of
that what you will but congratulations
to this week's giveaway winner Anna see
you in a twenty-dollar amazon gift card
be sure to private message me on the
back end of my channel so I get your
contact info and there is a new round of
the giveaway this week too all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave a comment on this video so we're
going a lot closer to season six we'll
probably see an official season 6
trailer in the next month or so towards
the end of this month or in February
sometime so we don't hold your breath or
anything but it is coming really soon so
while you guys wait for my next video to
post you can click your ATAR all about
the winds of winter delay it's not the
end of the world it's just going to come
a little bit later in the year and you
can click here for the Deadpool trailer
i just posted thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
you